I grew up in Rome I spent the first 17
years of my life in Rome
therefore speaking Italian as a first
language and going to a French lycée so
speaking and learning to think via the
French system although my parents are
American expatriates so I grew up
essentially bilingual and then
trilingual it learned English fluently
only when I was almost 18 in came to
school in the u.s. after having been at
the Sorbonne in 1968 and of course all
foreign students in 1968 at the Sorbonne
or with people holding foreign passports
were asked to leave after the what they
called the even more and so I came to
New York at that point and studied in
the American system and became a speaker
of English and as a result of that wrote
in English although I can't imagine
having written in any other language
because the English language is such an
extraordinary language for poetry and so
I feel very lucky that it turned out
that way
you